I just want desserts should Japanese
dessert and everybody know I eat it when
I sleep I know very little about
Japanese desserts I love desserts
Japanese culture tends to be very
detailed in what they do very vexing
these to be hella pretty cute I want the
green one oh okay
I wanted this one so congratulations can
we look at this detailing like they have
the seeds in the middle of the flower
the texture from the mochi and inside
you get like that red bean coming in
it's like nice and sweet
this is a grape good you know it just
had so much care and so much tradition
yeah and the color in yours my god oh
yes always look cool Eunice I think I've
ever seen that it's very saucy yeah just
smells like soy sauce is a little bit
savory pancakes does days like pancake
I don't really do pancake I don't care
for this one as much clay there's a
pretty good I'm so into those it's sweet
but it's also got like this hint of like
saltiness
so balances all out
Oh oh [ __ ] it's flubber
I don't want my mic humaneness to
destroy this artistry this would be a
great boomerang oh great it's just the
right amount of sweetness and it's light
so it's not like too overwhelming to
your palate yeah it tastes like wow what
guy literally just going to point five
million dollars in my bank and I'm gonna
treat myself to fancy food the layer the
layers the detail gaze
it looks like a jello cake oh the bird
it's a Twitter bird that's nice yeah
buddy a bird and a son whoa oh no I hit
something it was delicious
it has like a like a very firm
gelatinous feel I'm like like the junkie
like bite into it just like soften like
right Safari yeah the agar part is
definitely like very gelatin need yeah
like imagine I'm very like sick jello
I'm just not a jello lady it's like
we're sleeping here in the US on our
dessert game all of these candies are
delicious for me everyone was like a
different lover I think a lot of times
like you get like a dessert especially
with like cakes with like fondant stuff
or like it looks really cool but it
doesn't really taste very good
honestly that dango I think it changed
my life yes we come to the
[Music]
let it go it's a [ __ ] me me says
they belong to me